[MUSIC]
I'm in the locker room with my
Washington University and St.
Louis basketball teammates.
Blasting the only
acceptable pump up song for
2011, Jason Derulo's Riding Solo.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm a freshman point guard trying to
take it all in and
doing my best not to mess up.
The game that we're getting ready for
is the one we've been waiting for
our entire lives,
a national championship game.
As we ran out of the tunnel onto
the court, I anticipated the usual
adrenaline rush that accompanies
the sound of a rising crowd.
But the mild applause we
received was a total buzz kill.
Besides our families and a few loyal
super fans, the stands were mostly empty.
Our National Championship game,
turned into something like
a practice scrimmage with referees.
I don't like showing pictures from
that game because the empty stands in
the background make me
feel self-conscious.
We lost that game, but
I walked away with a deeper sadness.
This is the reality for
many women athletes today.
They spend years and dedication to their
craft, but their amazing abilities and
accomplishments go under appreciated.
What a serious missed opportunity.
Every person, sports fan or not,
can appreciate the beauty and
promise of women's sports.
You should watch women's sports.
You won't be disappointed.
Let's take a step back and
think about how we got here.
Three damaging myths
surrounding women's sports
deserve to be redressed and debunked.
Women athletes aren't as talented as men,
women's sports are boring, and
women's sports don't matter.
Let's start with the first one.
Women athletes aren't as talented as men.
Under this rationale,
if Elena Delle Donne can't dunk like
LeBron James, it's not worth watching.
If Allyson Felix can't beat Justin Gatlin
in a head to head 100m dash,
it's not worth watching.
While it is true that men have larger
muscle mass that makes them stronger and
longer arms and
legs that make them faster,
it's also true that there
are other markers of athleticism.
Being a good athlete is about skill,
finesse, IQ, determination,
and sportsmanship all of which women
hold in just as large quantity as men.
Let's take a look at some of the most
talented women athletes I know.
You've probably heard of Serena Williams,
Simone Biles, and Megan Rapinoe.
But I'd like to introduce you to
three you might not have heard of.
First, Gwen Jorgensen,she's the 2016
Olympic gold medalist in triathlon.
She was an accountant at Ernst and
Young and
left her jobs become a full
time professional triathlete.
She's now looking to become the first
American woman to win gold in the marathon
since 1984.
Claressa Shields, two-time Olympic
gold medalist in women's boxing.
Claressa has a really inspiring story,
she grew up in Flint,
Michigan in a childhood that was marked by
poverty, abuse, and a speech impediment.
And finally, Kate Courtney,
top American mountain biker.
She went here, to Stanford.
Kate loves sharks and Shark Week.
In fact, on her bike, where it says
her name, she's changed the a in Kate
to resemble a shark fin because she says
that's what her riding style is like.
She lurks beneath the surface and then
she pounces right when the time is right.
Stories like these,
of talented women with fun and
inspiring backgrounds abound in women's
sports, we just don't hear about them.
Only 4% of sports media coverage
goes to women's sports.
So it's not that women
athletes aren't talented.
It's that we don't have enough exposure
to be able to assess talent accurately.
Second, women's sports are boring.
I'll turn that on its head and
ask, what even is boredom?
Because if you're bored
watching some of these events,
it's not a problem with the athletes.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I want to
talk about one of my favorite women's
sporting events from recent history,
the 2018 Olympic final
in cross-country skiing.
The American skier,
Jessie Diggins, rounded the curve
to come down the home stretch.
She was a few lengths behind.
And she put on one of the most powerful
performances I've ever seen to cross
the finish line and win Olympic
gold in this photographic finish.
Or how about Nneka Ogwumike, Stanford
grad, who hit this game winning shot as
she felt to her back to win the WNBA
championship for the Los Angeles Sparks.
So you're going to tell me that
watching NASCAR cars- > [LAUGH]
>> Go around in circles 200 times in a row
is more exciting than this?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or that ESPN should
put professional corn hole on-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Instead of professional women's soccer.
The excitement around
women's sports is there.
It's up to us to pay attention.
Women's Sports, don't matter.
The World Series and Super Bowl captivate
men's sports fans for weeks at a time.
Because women's sports doesn't have
the infrastructure or the media coverage,
it can be difficult to know when the big
games and competitions are happening.
But that doesn't mean that
women's sports don't matter.
Girls and women who play sports have
higher levels of self confidence,
higher motivation to achieve
long term goals, and
lower levels of obesity,
diabetes, and certain cancers.
Playing sports can translate
into off field success as well.
Research from Ernst and
Young and ESPN shows that of senior
level business women in America,
94% have a background in sport, and 52%
of them competed at the collegiate level.
So if you care about
the future of our country and
want to see a more equitable world,
you'll know women's sports matter.
Professional women athletes are also some
of the most amazing advocates out there.
You might have heard of the US
soccer teams fight for equal pay.
But did you know that the US hockey team
went through a similar battle in 2017?
When Colin Kaepernick knelt to protest
systemic racism in our country,
US soccer star Megan Rapinoe was
the first to kneel in solidarity.
And arguably the best basketball player
in the world, Maya Moore, has taken
two years away from the game to advocate
for prison reform, specifically for
a man she believes is wrongly convicted
and sits on death row in Missouri.
Once you know these women and
their stories, it's hard not to care.
The same way that we draft and
follow our fantasy football leagues, or
latch onto contestants in the Bachelor,
that's what I want for women's sports.
Which brings me to what you
can do to better support.
At Stanford, it could mean watching one or
two events live.
We have some of the most amazing athletes
in the world right here on our campus.
In the last year, our women's soccer,
volleyball, swimming and diving,
rowing, water polo, and tennis teams
have all won national championships.
That's six in the last year.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> When you're in a bar or
restaurant, ask the server to turn one
of the TVs to a women's sporting event.
Even if you're only casually watching
the game, other patrons will stroll in and
see that it's on TV and
it will start to become more normalized.
I can't understate the importance
of stories in women's sports.
Invest in learning about a player or
a team and follow them for a season.
Maybe it's someone who's from
your hometown or home state or
someone who speaks out about
a cause you care about.
Once you're invested in their success,
I think you'll find it's
hard not to pay attention.
Another thing you can do is consider being
a coach for a local youth girls team.
Being a constant presence in a young
girl's life can make a world
of difference.
And finally, as business school students,
I would remiss
not to plant a seed that maybe one day
you should buy a women's sports team.
>> [LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE]
>> And grow it into the most successful
sports franchise in
the history of the world.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I still have a recurring dream.
It happens about once a month or so.
I'm back in college,
this time as a senior.
I'm in that locker room getting ready for
another national championship game.
But this time,
when I run out onto the court,
I'm met with a wall of applause
that sends me back on my heels.
I want this to be more than a dream.
I want it to be the reality for
the next generation of female athletes.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]